[Music]
hey watch one of those movies yeah Jesus
Christ don't like 8 - you - those bro we
get it we get it
is he dressed like a woman in real life
you'd have to ask him gun to the head
yeah pumps are size 14 pump it is from
yeah I listen you got a respect respect
transgenders a thousand percent you know
what I mean you got two but I think like
after city like after 60 if you keep
wearing makeup and wigs and see you do
it about 4 ladies like Christie
Brinkley's over 60 listen but still
wearing makeup but if your house is in
Crawford if you're a transgender and
you're over 60
you should probably dress like old
ladies right and with the with the gray
wig laughs you got again there's
different ladies like look Christie
Brinkley have you seen what she looks
like now I think she's 64 she's still
hot done
stunning hot no filter not long legs no
no literally Elisabeth Hurley's
Instagram is goddamned hilarious it is
all her and her underwear every pic
child to shape 85 years old 52 she's
like 54 55 that was very every picture
allegedly every picture of her is her
and her underwear on her Instagram she's
so bad looking good oh dude look good I
think oh she does is eat go to the gym
and take pictures in her underwear I
think that's all she does she's earned
it yeah man look she's letting everybody
know while she still got this body she's
putting that [ __ ]
front and center haleh she's 85 years
old 85 before 50 54 Christie Brickley 65
god damn early 54 that ain't yes dude
she's hot I think that if you saw her at
a club you think that's a 35 year old
smoking look at that smoke show how dare
you introduce No show me the full screen
that's her yes dude she's hotter no no
that's her in her pool
when you got that Elizabeth Hurley cash
the picture right there with her in the
bikini on the floaty thing on the on the
bring bingo every bit pink filming hot
is [ __ ] wit her body man she keeps it
toned she has that like a 30 year old
son she imagine bein her son her kids 50
she a woman like her with massive
amounts of resources and she can go to
all the best doctors hormone-replacement
all the best like look at look at that
that's her and her daughter dude she's
hot as [ __ ] she's 65 years old look at
her
come on son daughter looking like Doug
Lee friend your mom's hot though yeah if
you doing Elizabeth Hurley has ass shots
Elizabeth Hurley zas hard for me to
believe I think at 50 you're asked why
guys can do it guys can do it though
guys have different kind of asses their
long dresses holds but you can get asked
jobs these days you know guys like ass
implants no guys no no God no God no
guys well here's the thing good starting
to develop ass cancer they're starting
to develop cancer in the same areas
where women were some women are getting
breast cancer from implants it's it's
not always getting passed yes yes but
she can't say yes but from the implant
or are they doing the Brazilian bone
which is fat let me answer it's a
reaction to the implants
your body doesn't want foreign
substances in its body if you put
something in your body a piece of
plastic and then your body like has to
go why's is here what the [ __ ] is is
when your body starts to fight it
and then you develop scar tissue around
it that's why a lot of older ladies that
got boob jobs if you hug them there it
feels like they got two basketballs in
their chest it's [ __ ] weird touch
scar tissue yeah here we go
Curtis blades and what his homeboys name
say that name Brendan doll dude come on
mouth rockmouth abdul-hakeem off whoo
big fellow
Curtis blades with this big shot the
deep shot whose mug shot is that over
there Richard Pryor oh [ __ ]
to go look at this crazy
Curtis plates already on his back my
boys hairy so you got a good picture
Christie Brinkley's ass there must be
one out there I don't know unless you're
doing unless she's doing squats every
other day in the Olympic Training Center
in Colorado
it ain't happy I'm Tony Mann yes you
guys are hating on implants but there's
the brazilian butt-lift which is an
implant it's all its fat from your body
and your arable if you can tell that's
what they don't gotta [ __ ] put
something in your ass to make it round
that means you've never worked out your
legs are not gonna match that ass but
that doesn't work on some girls because
they don't have enough fat for it so
where do is they put plastic in there
those are the implant those are the
girl's ass implants do not count I agree
I would rather I would rather marry a
chick with a flat no no a million
percent no way it's never [ __ ] doggy
style
no missionary go old fashion style never
flipper old-fashioned elder you never
flipped that Mitchell over fashion style
like olden days who do you think was the
first guy to [ __ ] a girl doggy style
like what you are
right in front of the tree right in
front of the tree eating an apple you
put the Apple on her Apple missionary
came listen Mary started like 200 years
ago missionary
[Laughter]